and also if i'm his team i don't  have him take this year off where he's  getting sucked off on his yacht and in  cochi pajamas and him fight you know for  a title  you haven't fighted tony ferguson or  something like that you don't throw him  the [ __ ] top one or two guys that to  me that's just bad management you know  get him a win  get you know get him get him his  bearings back gives confidence back and  then you can shoot for that stuff but to  take this much time off and get sucked  off on your boat and then come in and  fight the number one guy in the world is  insane to me insane they're doing a  disservice and also she cuts the sh that  the shelf life on him being a big  pay-per-view star him being the biggest  number one gate because he keeps losing  if he gets bad and he's competing  against these really you know savages  all the [ __ ] time with these long  last terrible business plan